Democrats split between the radicals and
the sane Sanders in Elizabeth Warren
form an unlikely team up and marianne
williamson comes away with the surprise
victory and also crystals i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
Marianne Marianne Marianne it was great
okay so it was democratic debate round
to fight night one it happened all last
night where we go through all of it
we're going to explain why Marianne
Williamson her a good big night actually
had kind of some import to it I'll
explain in just one second first a rise
in geopolitical tensions have led to a
five-year high in gold prices that is
not a shock when there's uncertainty
people rush to gold Iran has announced
will break the uranium stockpile limit
they agreed to under the nuclear deal
which is not a shock either is it a
coincidence that gold prices have been
been rising steadily since the tanker
bombings no because again gold is that
safe haven against uncertainty for a lot
of people is it part of your plan will
attributes' part of my plan can your
plan afford another hit like the last
downturn when the S&P dropped 50% you
should hedge at least a little bit
against inflation and uncertainty and
instability with precious metals I don't
mean like take all your assets liquidate
them and buy gold I mean that it is
diversifying against the market and
that's always a good idea having
something in gold gold has never been
worth zero it is the all-purpose
currency and there is something to be
said for the idea that at least part of
your portfolio is going to be insured
against the possible chaos to come
always Birch gold group they're the
folks that I trust
they've thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau contact
Birch gold group right now get a free
information kit on physical precious
metals see if diversifying into gold and
silver makes sense for you they have a
comprehensive 16 page kit shows how gold
and silver can protect your savings you
can get that no-cost no-obligation kit
by texting Ben to 47 47 47 again text
Ben my name too 47 47 47 Birch gold the
folks that I trust with precious metals
investing alrighty so it was the
democratic debates round 2 fight night 1
so tonight is the other one tonight is
the one with Joe Biden and Kamala Harris
and Cory Booker and it's gonna be all
race all the time can old Joe get up off
the mat but last night was fascinating
for another reason it really highlighted
the division inside the Democratic Party
between the sane and the insane the
insane right now have their hands on the
steering wheel when I say the insane I
mean the people who are proposing
massive radical change to the United
States people like Elizabeth Warren
people like Bernie Sanders people yes
like Pete Budaj edge who originally came
out as a moderate and then has sort of
back
tract ever since all the way to the
point where he is now suggesting you're
a bad Christian if you don't support his
ideas on minimum wage and so there is
this radical wing of the party then
there is the moderate wing of the party
and actually last night on the stage the
moderates outnumbered the radicals the
moderates on stage little folks like Amy
Klobuchar and Tim Ryan from Ohio and
Chon's Eleni who actually showed pretty
well from a congressperson and Steve
Bullock from Montana and what these
divisions between the radicals and the
same showed is that when asked very
simple questions the radicals simply
could not defend their policies they're
running far to the left on the idea of
grand visions grandiose plans for the
future and the moderates are sitting
over there going guys you're gonna lose
right you pushing too hard means that it
will be a referendum on our policy it
won't be a referendum on President Trump
anymore so they were trying to grip the
coattails of these radical Democrats and
try to haul them back over the edge of
the cliff and while it was pretty
obvious that the radicals had no answers
it obviously wasn't working in the hall
because the applause lines were all for
the radicals in the hall which makes
sense it's a primary but all of these
clips are going to live on forever this
is why Rahm Emanuel former Congress
person former chief of staff for Barack
Obama was saying openly yesterday that
the Democrats are busy alienating an
enormous percentage of the population
with their prescriptions now the person
who came away with the big win last
night was the person who channeled the
spirit of radicalism without actually
any of the policy see well last night
exposed more than anything else is that
folks who are very into the radicalism
of the Democratic Party very into the
radical left Medicare for all we know
none no first use of nuclear weapons
people want to decriminalize illegal
immigration what this showed this debate
last night is that it's not that those
policies are inherently popular or
inherently wonderful people aren't
resonating to the policies they're
resonating to the notion put forward by
the radicals that a change in policy
will occasion a change in the spirit of
man Barack Obama's appeal in 2008 was
not a policy appeal he did not campaign
on policy for five minutes of that
entire campaign the reason that Barack
Obama was very popular is because he
campaigned on two things one that he was
going to be a unifying figure in the
wake of the Bush administration and not
only was he going to be a unifying
figure he was going to be a unifying
racial figure
meaning that the greatest drama and and
cruelty in American history was going to
be rectified by President Obama who is
going to bring all the parties back to
the table he's gonna bring everybody
together we could resonate around the
idea of a black president who signified
the progress that America had made and
then all Americans would be treated as
Americans rather than as members of
subgroups right that was Barack Obama's
chief appeal and that was tied to
another appeal that Michelle Obama
spelled out I found it incredibly
off-putting at the time I still find it
incredibly off-putting she said during
the campaign that Barack was going to
force you to be better he was going to
change your spirits he was gonna change
your souls it was a religious appeal and
overtly religious appeal and that was
appealing to a lot of folks on the left
because the real vision of Marxism and
most American leftism is tied to the
ideas of Karl Marx it's what
distinguishes American leftism from
normal sort of moderate policy or
conservatism the roots of leftism lie in
a materialist definition of reality in
which true troubles in all of America's
in all american walks can be boiled down
largely to the inequalities produced by
capitalism and by free markets and by
property ownership if you read Marx one
of the things that mark says pretty
obviously in the communist manifesto is
he talks about the idea that Marxism
will transform men the man is malleable
and that Marxism will make men different
that the reason man is bad is because
man has been shaped by his
socio-political environment in order to
be bad that capitalism free markets
property ownership via these have made
man lesser and that in the future
inevitably man will become greater as he
lets go of these things and that's an
overtly spiritual appeal it's actually a
religious appeal marianne williamson
last night on the stage was making
religious appeals and those religious
appeals are more in line with today's
politics than the sort of technocratic
politics that dominated america from
basically the Eisenhower administration
all the way through the George W Bush
administration the the spiritual appeal
is what got Barack Obama elected in 2008
and it's the spiritual appeal that
Conell Trump elected in 2016 Donald
Trump didn't make a policy appeal at any
point no point in 2016 did Donald Trump
really talk about policy instead he
talked about the quote-unquote spirit of
America making America great again
quote-unquote restoring the American
soul right that was the sort of idea it
was a religious appeal and when he meant
by restoring the American soul unlike
the vast majority of people in the media
who lie and say that it was all about
white responds to Barack Obama and all
of this when he said that he wanted to
make America great again that was a
spiritual appeal what he meant was he
wants an America that was rooted in
fundamental ideals of unity where we
were all firing our guns in the same
direction now he wasn't clear about what
the direction would be he was very vague
about that which was my main criticism
with him one of many in 2016 but that
was a spiritual appeal well last night
the only person who was talking on a
spiritual level was Marianne Williamson
and people have been mocking her for
this I've mocked her for this you know
the pretensions and the crystals and the
massage oils and all and the auras and
the penumbra's and all of this kind of
stuff and it is weird it's weird but
there was something she was doing last
night that operated on a different level
than the other Democratic candidates
this doesn't mean she's gonna win the
nomination it does mean that whichever
Democrat channels the zeitgeist that
Marianne Williamson is attempting to
channel is going to win the nomination
and maybe the presidency because what
she was doing last night was not talking
about the wonders of medicare-for-all
what she was doing last night instead
was talking about changing the American
soul and in a debate where the moderates
were basically kicking around the
radicals on policy she's the only one
who rose above it so she was saying the
same sort of stuff I mean she did an
interview last night where she was
specifically asked what kind of Democrat
was she just who she was asked this by
Anderson Cooper what kind of Democrat
are you and Mary Ann Williams is
Marianne Williamson is charmingly kooky
I mean even obviously Anderson Cooper is
is very much charmed by her and she's
wholly she's inherently hilarious
because she's charmingly kooky but she
says in the middle of this interview in
the one substantive point that she is a
Bernie Sanders Elizabeth Warren Democrat
but that's not what came across last
night because again she wasn't speaking
at the level of politics she was
speaking at the level of dark forces and
American spirits and all the rest of
this here's where she identifies
politically and also why she's kind of
charming I mean I just find it really
interesting this notion that a plan is
not enough and
who else does anybody else that you have
seen of all what does there's anybody
else well yeah no one else like you on
that stage that I can I don't I don't
take positions but I can tell you that
it's a position I will stand by she's
travelling kooky but then she finished
that by saying she's an Elizabeth Warren
Bernie Sanders Democrat meaning she she
agrees with them on policy but that's
not what came across last night cuz
that's not the level upon which she was
campaigning okay so now let's get into
the details of this debate first of all
you want to talk about how radical the
Democrats are let's talk about Tom Perez
so Tom Perez is the head of Democratic
National Committee
he was made that while Barack Obama was
still president he was the former head
of the Civil Rights Division of the DOJ
under Barack Obama where he was
extraordinarily radical himself I know
folks who served in the DOJ at that time
in the Civil Rights Division and it was
fairly obvious that Tom Perez was
orienting that division in one
particular way toward targeting one
particular sort of discrimination while
ignoring other forms of discrimination
any case Tom Perez leads off this thing
staring at the crowd all revved up and
he starts talking about global warming
and then he gets into universe warming
which is not a thing because global
warming is reliant on carbon emissions
on earth that create thickening of
certain chemical levels in the
atmosphere of the earth Mars is not
warming so here is Tom Perez saying
silly things climate change because
climate change is an economic crisis
it's a public health crisis it's a moral
crisis
okay so it yeah man everyone's get all
revved up yeah well there he is being as
radical as possible and then the
Democrats are like why aren't people
resonating to John's Eleni cuz the head
of your party is a crazy person who's
standing up there talking about universe
warming wouldn't what by the way if well
if global warming were actually about
universe warming then carbon emissions
wouldn't be the problem what day would
be the Sun right that is the only that
is the only body capable of warming the
universe so if we were just talk about
the Sun heating up it'd be a very
different question then then the
emissions that are coming out of your
cows but it will get to the actual
debate in just one second but that was
the setup the payoff was Democrats
cheering for everything radical well
logically Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders were absolutely exposed by the
moderates on the stage last night is
pretty amazing actually I'll get to that
in just one second first when I love an
advertiser's product so much that
actually buy one as a gift for a
relative that means that I really love
it well I actually bought a helix sleep
mattress for my sister on the occasion
of her wedding because they are just
great they're personalized just for you
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you no matter how
you sleep on the side back hot sleeper
whatever it is hulex can make what your
body needs just go to helix sleep comm
slash men take their two minutes sleep
quiz they will match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life for couples helix can
even split that mattress down the middle
providing individual support needs and
feel preferences for each side they've
got a 10 year warranty you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but I promise you will how do I
prominent cuz I have a helix sleep
mattress it is indeed phenomenal helix
is offering up to 125 bucks off all
mattress orders for our listeners get up
to 125 bucks off at helix sleep comm
slash Ben that's helix sleep comm / ben
from - 125 bucks off your mattress order
helix sleep calm / Ben go check them out
now after I took the 2 minutes sleep
quiz we got the personalized mattress
it's fantastic you should have one -
helix sleep calm / Ben use the slash
band to get up to 125 bucks off helix
sleep calm slash man okay so let's jump
into the actual debate so everybody sort
of gave their opening statements and
their opening statements made fairly
clear where exactly they are on the
spectrum
both Lauren is Val is vying for the
progressive wing of the Democratic Party
against Bernie Sanders now what was
weird about this debate last night is
you would have expected at some point
Warren to go after Sanders or Sanders to
go after Warren instead they seemed sort
of content to leave each other alone and
go after the moderates that's not going
to help either of them because this is
Highlander that could be only one if
Warren and Sanders stay in the race Joe
Biden is the nominee it's that simple if
Warren and Sanders stay in the race
together and they're both earning double
digits Joe Biden is the nominee one has
to take out the other
well Sanders isn't going anywhere he
feels like I ran this race in 2016 I
should have won I'm not going anywhere
and Elizabeth Warren feels bad that she
didn't jump in in 2016 so she's not
going anywhere so at a certain point
they've got to turn their guns on each
other that did not happen last night
instead they're trying to demonstrate
how radical they are so Elizabeth Warren
has been trying to have it both ways
she's super radical just like Sanders
but also she's kind of moderate well no
she's just a radical so here's Elizabeth
Warren making the pitch that the way
that the Democrats win the White House
is with big ideas which of course is
idiocy by polling data the way the
Democrats win the White House is by
standing there and pointing at President
Trump that's how they win if they talk
about radical policy ideas they lose and
as we'll see there were some Democrats
on stage last night who actually pointed
this out so here's Elizabeth Warren
saying we need courage we need strength
and the base cheering along good luck
with this we're not gonna solve the
urgent problems that we face with small
ideas and spinelessness we're gonna
solve them by being the democratic party
of big structural change okay so big
structural change
that's her stick okay and then she was
asked this is my favorite part of the
day there are a couple points where
Warren really sort of demonstrated what
she is so tapper asked Warren about her
statement that she is a capitalist she
says why are you a capitalist and Morin
basically says I'm a capitalist because
I'm a communist thank you I win that's
how we get back here senator Warren you
make it a point to say that you're a
capitalist is that your way of
convincing voters that you might be a
safer choice than senator Sanders it is
my way of talking about I know how to
fight and I know how to win Democrats
win when we figure out what is right
and we get out there and fight for it I
am Not Afraid and for Democrats to win
you can't be afraid either boy she a
low-rent Hillary Clinton my goodness
she's rehearsed and she has canned but I
love that her answer to is the reason
that you're saying that you're a
capitalist because you don't want to be
Bernie Sanders her saying yes basically
she's no it is my way of talking about
how I know how to fight and I know how
to win meaning if I say that I'm not a
capitalist and I go the way Bernie so
I'm not doing that so basically she just
answered yes to a question to what she
answered no how horrible is Elizabeth
Warren Elizabeth Warren is so horrible
john delaney who's an actual business
person was was asked about the wealth
tax and before he starts to answer you
know Don Lemon who is just as we will
see the worst Democrat debate
facilitator every terrible because he
should be on the stage if he actually
wants to running she just run John
zelena's asked about as well Elizabeth
Warren literally stood there and took
her hands and started doing this with
her hands in eagerness at taking John
Delaney's money I mean it's unbelievable
here is that moment is more than 65
million dollars that would make you
subject to senator Warren's proposed
wealth tax on the assets of the richest
75,000 homes
households or so in the United States
what in the hell is wrong with this
person what in the hell is wrong with
her she's sitting there and she's
literally she's literally taking her own
hands and rubbing her hands in
anticipation of taking John Delaney's
wealth who are you why what gives you
the right to rub your hands in
anticipation and Glee and taking
somebody else's money she's so eager to
take his money it's incredible
does that seem like somebody who is
desperate to help poor people or
desperate to hurt rich people what does
that seem like to you that's Elizabeth
Warren in a nutshell and by the way if
you think that Republicans won't cut
that and say this is Elizabeth Warren on
your money you are wrong I would cut
that ad tomorrow because that is
Elizabeth Warren on your money as we
will see by the way with regard to
Elizabeth Warren she has no answers when
it comes to how she's gonna pay for any
of her programs and she won't even tell
the truth about the fact that her
programs are gonna cost the middle class
an awful lot of money
okay so that was Elizabeth Warren's
pitch that was mirrored by Bernie
Sanders so warned
Tanner's are just two sides of the same
very weird coin so Bernie Sanders was in
full Bernie mode last night I mean he
had turned the spinal tap speaker all
the way up to 11 there's a lot of
yelling hearing aid wasn't working
properly he had really gotten the
caffeine pro pudding in his veins and
that pudding was flowing freely he's
like there was crack in the pudding and
Bernie Sanders was going off and so
here's Bernie doing Bernie we have got
to take on Trump's racism his sexism
xenophobia and come together in an
unprecedented unprecedented grassroots
movement to not only defeat Trump but to
transform our economy and our government
he is one continuous Howard Dean scream
and people are loving it people are into
it okay and then he would get people to
judge so Budaj edge is now an also-ran
everybody's still treating him like he's
a quasi frontrunner he is not he is not
in the top tier of candidates he polls
well below 10% he is not anything he's
future Secretary of Education people to
judge right I mean in a democratic
administration that's where this is
going so here is P Buddha judge talking
about all of the why he should be
elected even though he is what two years
older than I am he's thirties 35 he's 37
years old so people who to judge says
that we have to we have to go radical we
have to go big or go home science tells
us we have 12 years before we reach the
horizon of catastrophe when it comes to
our climate by 2030 the average house in
this country will cost half a million
bucks and woman's right to choose may
not even exist we are not going to be
able to meet this moment by recycling
the same arguments policies and
politicians that have dominated
Washington for as long as I have been
alive
okay so again it's going to be I'm young
and I'm radical and I'm here okay so
that was the radical wing of the
Democratic Party last night then he got
to the reasonable people and I'm when I
say reasonable I don't mean Republican I
just mean people who are not totally
crazy
okay Amy Klobuchar gets up there and she
says listen a lot of people are gonna
promise you stuff but um we have to live
in reality and I can win you're gonna
hear a lot of promises up here but I'm
going to tell you this yes I have bold
ideas that they are grounded in reality
and yes I will make some simple
I can win this I'm from the Midwest and
I bring anybody obviously that's not
inspiring anybody but what is but but it
is a reasonable pitch and that was the
pitch that was been made by a bunch of
different candidates on the stage last
night Steve Bullock who is the governor
of Montana he made the same pitch he
said listen you guys are all going crazy
right I was watching that last debate
and you are and you're more interested
in running to the left than winning an
election I come from a state where a lot
of people voted for Donald Trump let's
not kid ourselves he will be hard to be
yet watching that last debate folks seem
more concerned about scoring points or
outdoing each other with wish list
economics then making sure Americans
know we hear their voices and will help
their lives
this of course is exactly right if they
actually wanted to win john delaney who
had a good night last night from a
congressperson he said the same thing he
said we can go down the Sanders in and
Warren Road and then we'll eat and then
we'll lose then we'll lose folks we have
a choice we can go down the road that
senator Sanders and Senator Warren want
to take us with his with bad policies
like Medicare for all free everything
and impossible promises that will turn
off independent voters and get Trump
re-elected that's what happened with
McGovern that's what happened with
Mondale that's what happened with
Dukakis correct correct
okay so again this broke down very
quickly into Sanders and more and versus
the quote-unquote moderates in the field
and then there's marianne williamson as
we'll see we'll get to that in just one
second first hiring you used to be hard
not anymore
when someone makes the slightest Monson
significant mistake here at the Daily
wire they know that they are living on
razor's edge because we always have the
backup of zip recruiter available also
we don't fire people very often here at
daily wear and if we want new employees
we are constantly hiring we use zip
recruit comm slash daily wire zip
recruiter sends your job posting to over
100 of the web's leading job boards but
they don't stop there as applications
come in zip recruiter analyzes each one
spotlights the top candidates see never
miss a great match zip recruiter is so
effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter got
a quality candidate through the site
within the very first day right now my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter dot-com slash daily wire
that's zip record calm / Dai ly WI re
zip recorder calm / daily wire zip
recruiters indeed the smartest way to
hire if you're looking to upgrade at
your business you need to find people
who are qualified for their jobs what
better way to do that then use zip
recruiter the same way we do right here
at the Daily wire zip recruiter comm /
daily wire you can try zip recruiter for
free when you do that
zip recruiter comm / daily wire okay so
the other Democratic candidate on the
stage was somewhat moderate is John
Hickenlooper the governor of Colorado
and he comes out a former governor of
Colorado he comes out and he says listen
your policies are not going to win you
any seats all the people who won seats
in last year's elections those people
are running on my policies not your
policies last year Democrats flipped
forty Republican seats in the House and
not one of those 40 Democrats support
the policies of our front runners at
center stage
hey that is correct correct okay so
again stage breaks down into radicals
versus moderates and then marianne
williamson
who's just out there and marianne
williamson again is making the same
pitch as bernie sanders our elizabeth
warren but she's making an actually more
honest pitch which is if you do what i
want we're gonna transform the spirit of
america either no not my thing i think
it's ugly in politics when political
leaders do this routine I don't like it
when Trump did it and like it would
Obama did it I don't think political
leaders are there to be our spiritual
mentors or guides I do not think the
political leaders are there to transform
our spirits I think the political
leaders are there to do the things they
promised they're going to do and ideally
to uphold the rights that are
established in the Constitution of the
United States but unfortunately I am in
the minority on this most people in the
United States want a leader who is going
to channel them they want the Wilsonian
big man who is going to channel their
spirit and marianne williamson and does
that better than anybody else on the
stage last night here she was in her
opening pitch in 1776 our founders
brought forth on this planet an
extraordinary new possibility it was the
idea that people no matter who they were
would simply have the possibility of
thriving and now it is time or
generation of Americans to rise up again
for an immoral economic system has
turned short-term profits for you
multinational corporations into a false
god and this new false God takes
precedence over the safety and the
health and the well-being of we the
American people and the people of the
world
and the planet on which we live ok so
again she's using keywords in sort of
the Spiritualist push and she's talking
about thriving which is a favorite word
of a lot of sort of secular humanists
she is talking about an amoral economic
system not an immoral like an a more
like a not we need a more reality and
she's talking about multinational
corporations as false gods these this is
all deeply spiritual language and it's
going to a level of the iceberg that the
other Democrats are not going to the
other Democrats are talking about policy
here on the top of the iceberg marianne
williamson is going beneath the surface
of the iceberg now again does that mean
she wins the nomination no it means that
she is channeling something in the
Democratic Party right now and in the
American political system more broadly
that goes deeper than the political
debate so I know we're not supposed to
take her seriously but she's gonna have
a moment she's gonna have a moment it's
happening right now okay now in a second
I want to get to the actual battles that
happen because as we will see the reason
Marianne Williamson sort of flies over
the top in this debate is because
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders on
any objective level brought Brack back
down to earth last night on their policy
okay so let's talk about that so there
was a lot of talk about health care last
night
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders both
pushing Medicare for all both lying
about it so Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren keep making the same case which
is sure we're gonna raise your taxes
although Elizabeth Warren lies about it
and says she won't they both say sure
we're gonna raise your taxes but in the
end you're gonna pay less for health
care which of course is not really true
in the sense that out-of-pocket you will
be paying more for health care because
you are paying from your tax dollars
whereas right now for the vast majority
of Americans their employer is paying
for their health care well let's let's
put it this way the employer is not
going to lower your salary based on your
health care benefits your health care
benefits will just go away and then you
will pay out of your own pocket for
health care which means in your pocket
will be less money for the vast majority
of Americans that's just a basic fact
your employer is mostly paying for your
health care at this point if you're in
the employment based market in any case
john delaney points this house because
John Zeleny isn't a crazy person and
Delaney says you keep talking about
taking away in the health insurance of
155 million people you
think that that's a real pitch you think
that's that's really what what you're
going to do and Bernie Sanders has no
answer except to get very angry and the
crowd gets angry along with him what I'm
talking about is really simple we should
deal with the tragedy be uninsured and
give everyone health care as a right but
why do we got to be the party of taking
something away no one is the country
they're running on telling half the
country that your health insurance is
illegal it says it right in the bill
okay that is exactly true that is
exactly true so Warren tries to jump in
right there and to save Bernie Sanders
right he says why do we have to be the
party of taking something away from
people and then Warren doesn't like the
idea that she was going to be castigated
as such which she will be she is taking
something away from people she is saying
that we have to make illegal private
health insurance in the United States in
order to achieve Medicare for all
Delanie points this out Warren has no
answer and then Delaney went on on
health care and he is correct exactly
correct calling her out for what this
plan is and I asked rural hospital
administrators one question if all your
bills were paid at the Medicare rate
last year what would happen and they all
look at me and say we would close but
the question is why do we have to be so
extreme why can't we just give everyone
health care as a right and allow them to
have choice okay so again then Dana Bash
jumps in we have to let it go but what
he's saying there is of course exactly
right if you say Medicare for all and
then you pay everything back at the
reimbursement rate of Medicare hospitals
will shut down that's just the reality
of the situation doctors will stop
taking Medicare as long as there is a
private alternative which is why people
like Elizabeth Warren are suggesting
that you got a ban the private
alternative and then Warren had to lie
about the cost of Medicare so here is
Jake Tapper grilling her on this would
you raise taxes on the middle class to
pay for Medicare for all offset
obviously by the elimination of
insurance premiums yes or no costs will
go up for billionaires and go up for
corporations for middle-class families
costs total costs will bode okay for
middle-class family total costs will go
down by what gradation
what metric well total costs go down
costing your employer or class out of
your pocketbook because those are not
quite the same thing
remember your employer is paying for
those benefits and then Bernie Sanders
got the same treatment from Tim Ryan and
John Delaney so Jake Tapper asks Bernie
Sanders he says I understand it would
provide universal coverage but can you
guarantee union members that the
benefits of Medicare for all will be as
good as the benefits that they're
representing their union reps fought
hard to negotiate now Sanders starts to
answer this question and then Ryan jumps
in and then Sanders gets mad and it's
anger at Sanders his anger that has made
him popular it is not Sanders his
policies this is why again marianne
williamson is channeling something a
thing Bernie Sanders is the closest to
the other thing right Bernie Sanders is
the closest thing to an alternative
which is just sheer rage just anger
yelling screaming but marianne
williamson is doing sort of the same
thing as Bernie and sort of the same
thing as Obama and we'll see that in
just one second here is Bernie's answer
to this I understand that it would
provide universal coverage but can you
guarantee those union members that the
benefits under Medicare for all will be
as good as the benefits that their
representatives their union reps fought
hard to negotiate about two things they
will be better because Medicare for all
is comprehensive it covers all health
care needs for senior citizens it will
finally include dental care hearing aids
and eyeglasses second of all everybody's
very excited I wrote the dumb bill well
note what you what you don't know is
that Medicare is going to guarantee a
same level of coverage as cadillac
medical plans that unions have
negotiated in fact I can guarantee you
they won't it won't be the same thing
your care will be is good because
Medicare is not as good we know what
Medicare looks like people purchase
supplemental insurance through Medicare
Advantage it's why Medicare Advantage
exists it's a Bernie as just lying out
his but there but he said damn and so
everyone gets very excited so as I say
this contrast between radical left and
moderate it goes well for the crowd in
the room but for the rest of the
election it's not going to go well for
Democrats because it won't just be
democrats in the room at that point
now again marianne williamson makes a
different pitch marianne williamson gets
up and she says about health care i'm a
I'm not gonna talk about medicare for
all or not Medicare for all instead
we're just gonna talk about big ideas
big ideas and people
resonating tunas we're talking about
here tonight as what's wrong with
American politics and the Democratic
Party needs to understand that we should
be the party that talks not just about
symptoms but also about causes when it
when we're talking about health care we
need to talk about more than just the
health care plan we need to realize we
have a sickness care rather than a
health care system we need to be the
party talking about why so many of our
chemical policies and our food policies
and our agricultural policies and our
environmental policies and even our
economic policies are leading to people
getting sick to begin with yeah and
again she is doing something that is
different than all the other Democrats
the reason I keep bringing up Williamson
is not just me I'm not just standing for
Marianne here hey the reason that I'm
talking about Williamson is because she
was the number one searched googled
person in the debate last night in every
single state except Montana in Montana
they were governor and the number one
search was there governor Steve bullet
they were trying to google whether he
was in fact their governor cuz no one
knows it's Montana yeah but the fact is
that marianne williamson was doing
something different than everyone else
on the stage last night as we will see
this was a race between radicals for the
left moderates trying to hold them back
and marianne williamson just going right
over the top it's it was really kind of
fascinating on a on a base political
level we'll get some more of that in
just one second first reminder gang next
month we are taking our backstage show
on the road for a special one-night only
event August 21st the beautiful Terrace
Theatre in Long Beach California I know
it's a bit of a drive for those of you
who are in Los Angeles but it's pretty
much our only event in LA area this year
so you should come on out and join us
it's me daily where god-king Jeremy
boring Andrew Clavin the execrable
Michael moles will all be there live
will be talking politics pop culture
answering your questions from the
audience tickets are on sale right now
at Daley wire.com slash backstage
including our limited VIP packages that
guarantee premium seating photos meet
and greets with each of us a gift from
me I'm shopping for it right now right
after the show and more so head on over
daily wire.com slash backstage get your
tickets today and I will see you there
and if I don't see you there I'll be
very disappointed and you personally yes
you I'll be disappointed so head on over
to daily wear comm slash backstage also
make sure that you go subscribe at daily
wire com it helps protect us from the
nastiness of the left that seeks to
g-platform us they come after us all the
time on everything from Twitter to
Facebook to Google they come after our
radio affiliates they there
constantly going after our advertisers
you guarantee that we can continue to
bring you hard-hitting content in an
honest fashion without having to worry
about the nastiness of the left I've
never I would never
massage my message for their pleasure
anyway that's not something I'm willing
to do but you make it possible for us to
continue to bring bring you the show so
please join the team over at Daily wire
comm when you do for 99 bucks here you
get this leftist here as hot or cold
tumblr you can enjoy it you can you can
really live the luxury of having one of
these go subscribe right now it's daily
wire.com we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so Democrats racing for to the left on
immigration Elizabeth Warren repeated
her nonsense about decriminalizing
border crossings which of course would
only incentivize people to cross the
border illegally between points of entry
instead of waiting to be processed at a
point of entry at which point you're
going to be presumably detained and then
family separations take place instead
you try to cross at a non port of entry
and then just enter the country
illegally and you wait for amnesty you
want to you want to encourage people to
cross that rio grande illegally in
significantly more dangerous conditions
than they would get in a port of entry
do exactly what Elizabeth Warren is
talking about right here so the problem
is that right now the criminalization
statute is what gives Donald Trump the
ability to take children away from their
parents it's what gives him the ability
to lock up people at our borders that
she's just--she's terrible and then
Bernie Santa this was really funny
Bernie Sanders is actually harsher on
the border than Warren so this would be
an area where you would expect Warren
and Sanders to go out one another a
little bit but it never happens Warren
and Sanders formed a weird team up
instead of actually going out one
another which was kind of fascinating
frankly so Bernie Sanders was asked
about the fact that soft border policies
create an incentive for people to cross
and get benefits especially since both
Warren I believe and certainly Sanders
have talked about giving free medical
care for illegal immigrants Sanders says
oh no no no we're gonna be tough on the
border which is kind of interesting you
want to provide undocumented immigrants
free health care and free college why
won't this drive even more people to
come to the US illegally this will have
a strong border protections but the main
point I want to make is that what Trump
is doing through his racism and in Sante
phobia is demonizing a group of people
and as president I will end that
demonization me so that is him avoiding
the question he says we'll have strong
border protections and then he just sort
of ignores it kind of kind of
interesting Steve Bullock of Montana
then jumps in he says guys you guys have
no idea you're talking about like you
don't you do not know what the hell you
are talking about and of course he's
exactly correct look I think this is a
part of the discussion that shows how
often these debates are detached from
people's lives we got a hundred thousand
people
going up the border right now if we
decriminalize entry if we get health
care too everyone will have multiples of
that
don't take my word that was President
Obama's homeland security secretary that
said that of course that's exactly right
but that's not where the heart and soul
the Democratic Party is right now the
heart is really the heart and soul are
with Marianne Williamson but the the
political corollary of that is that it's
really with Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders and that leads to this weird
situation where everybody on stage last
night who's proposing anything that was
that was reasonable was basically booed
off the stage and treated as an apostate
it was incredible so take take an
example the green New Deal so john
delaney makes a proposal on global
warming and climate change that is
actually fairly bipartisan there are
some Republicans who support this I'm
still considering whether it's
worthwhile or not whether it would be
effective or not but John Zeleny says
listen here's what we should do we
should put a price on carbon and then we
should have what's called the carbon
dividend there are a few Republicans who
are on board with this as I say I'm not
on board with this yet the carbon
dividend is basically the idea that
you're gonna tax carbon and then you're
gonna redistribute the money from the
use of carbon to other projects inside
the United States
the reason I'm not on board with it is
because I am Not sure that China and
India are gonna sign off on anything
similarly and then you have a serious
collective action problem in which we
are harming our economy specifically so
that we cannot actually lower global
warming if that's something we're
worried about in any case here is John
Delaney making a pitch that is actually
somewhat reasonable and then we will
hear Elizabeth Warren's completely
unreasonable pitch my plan which gets us
to Net Zero by 2050 which we absolutely
have to do for our kids and our
grandkids will get us there I put a
price on carbon take all the money give
it back to the American people in a
dividend that was introduced by me on a
bipartisan basis it's the only
significant bipartisan climate bill in
the Congress I'm okay so that is again
John Delaney being somewhat reasonable
then we get to Elizabeth Warren and she
says I'm just gonna dump money on it I'm
just gonna take a dump truck full of
money and pour it on global warming so I
proposed putting two trillion dollars in
so we do the research we then say anyone
in the world can use it so long as you
build it right here in America that will
produce about 1.2 million
FAK shirring jobs right here in Michigan
right here in Ohio absolute your
nonsense Barack Obama tried this with
his green jobs initiative under Van
Jones it was a complete fail she's
saying we're just gonna dump money on
this problem and it's going to solve
itself but again it's all about the
yelling and the screaming and the
enthusiasm and it's not X basically the
Democratic Party is now making a choice
whether they want to be the party of
jazz or that they want to be the party
of rock so original jazz actually took
skill it actually took skill it was all
about the ability to know different
harmonies and and to work with
sophisticated harmonies and to improvise
right that was original jazz then you
got to rock and rock is not about skill
rock is about enthusiasm it's about the
level of enthusiasm that you have well
the Democratic Party is choosing between
skill policies that work policies that
at least should be considered and just
rank enthusiasm and you can see that
rank enthusiasm is winning that's why
Bernie Sanders is still pulling up
around 20% right now although this did
lead to the funniest exchange of the
evening in which Tim Ryan got irritated
at the old man screaming at the clouds
and elsewhat him question what do you do
with an industry that knowingly for
billions of dollars in short-term
profits is destroying this planet I say
that it's criminal activity that cannot
be allowed Thank You senator Sanders
congressman your response yeah I would
just say I didn't say we couldn't get
there till 2040 Bernie you don't have to
yell I mean all I'm saying is
everybody's because they know it's true
old men screaming in clouds winning
elections hey then finally the Democrats
can it's amazing they did this entire
debate in Detroit it waited until the
end she gets questions of race and then
it just turned into a pander fest about
slavery reparations and the legacy of
racism in the United States listen we
can talk about the legacy of racism in
the United States if we want to do a
data-driven Drive into what level of
current endemic poverty is based on
historic racism and Jim Crow and what
level is based on individual actions
that keep people in intergenerational
poverty single motherhood lack of
education criminal activity and all the
rest and you can say that those things
are outgrowths of past systems of
discrimination I'm sure that's true
but the question when it comes to your
individual behavior is what is your
individual behavior going to be today
not did the legacy of Jim Crow
contribute to your individual behavior
the question is our force is beyond your
control the ones that are controlling
your life or is it stuff that is in your
control that is controlling your life we
can have all those sorts of
conversations Democrats don't want to
have any of them and so instead they
just pander just turns into slavery
reparations this and slavery reparations
that people who de jedge tried to pander
and failed and then and then so did
Elizabeth Horne and then marianne
williamson stepped in again it was her
night she's the one who had the best
night so people to judge said he had
this very awkward line where he said
that the racial divide lives within me I
like what the hell does that mean what
what what does that even like you're
white dude what as an urban mayor
serving a diverse community the racial
divide lives within me no I'm not sure
how that means then elizabeth warren it
jumps in and she of course is going to
to go as radical as you can because
she's gonna out enthusiasm everybody we
need to call out white supremacy for
what it is domestic terrorism the
country now where the president is
advancing environmental racism economic
racism criminal justice racism health
care racism the way we do better is to
fight back and show something better so
I have a plan for example on okay what
in the okay so it's environmental racism
iskender racism in that country okay
then marianne williamson steps in and
marianne williamson actually makes a
pitch that again is spiritual in nature
and thus when it comes to issues of race
is actually more attractive here's
marianne williamson
putting the slavery reparations question
in a way that actually sounds more
reasonable than the way democrats are
talking about it I assure you I lived in
Grosse Pointe what happened in Flint
would not have happened in Grosse Pointe
this is part of the dark underbelly of
Americans
and the entire conversation that we're
having here tonight if you think any of
this wonkiness is going to deal with
this dark psychic force of the
collectivized hatred that this president
is bringing up in this country then I'm
afraid that the Democrats are going to
see some very dark days we need to say
it like it is
okay so again she's wrong a Flint is
governed by minorities I mean the folks
who are the mayor of Flint is was black
at the time the folks who were involved
in the Flint water crisis were of
minority descent it wasn't white people
cramming down a situation on Flint by
the way they're all Democrats but what
she's actually saying there is more
speaking to the heart and soul of the
Democratic Party than anything that
Elizabeth Warren just said Elizabeth
Warren is substituting policy for
spirits and marianne williamson is
substituting spirit for policy and if
democrats have to choose i have a
feeling that marianne williamson whoever
channels that spirit best is going to is
going to do some damage in these
Democratic primaries now listen it's
real weird right image talk about the
dark psychic force of collectivized
hatred we must form a fellowship which
I'll call it the Fellowship of the Ring
we shall go and fight the dark psychic
force of collectivized hatred I told you
we'll toss the ring into the flames the
fiery furnace from whence it came
marianne williamson but again got a big
cheer I mean did you hear that big cheer
and then here she was more on race and a
better pitch than Elizabeth Warren to
look at evidence I appreciate what
congressman O'Rourke has said it is time
for us to simply realize that this
country will not heal the all that a
country is as a collection of people
people heal when there's some deep
truth-telling we need to recognize that
when it comes to the economic gap
between blacks and whites in America it
does come from a great injustice that
has never been dealt with that great
injustice okay again and she's talking
in a way and at a level that other
Democrats are not this is not just me
saying the Marian Woodson is the best
and I and I think that she should be the
dictate for us of the universe or
anything really what I'm saying about
marianne williamson obviously is that
she is doing something that i think that
the rest of the democratic party is
missing
and what the rest of the Democratic
Party is missing is that their appeal
right now is a spiritual appeal it is
not a policy appeal the policy appeal
failed on its own merits last night the
spiritual appeal of Williamson did not
fail not among Democrats and not among
moderates she is the Trump of the
Democratic Party except she's not as
famous if she were more famous she would
be leading this race right now among
Democrats it's pretty obvious that that
is the case by the way I mean listen to
the way that Williamson closed the
debate last night nobody else had
anything remotely memorable the only
memorable stuff that was said last night
was all said by Marianne Williamson here
was Marianne Williamson is closing yes
our problem is not just that we need to
defeat Donald Trump we need a plan to
solve institutionalized hatred
collectivized hatred and white
nationalism I want a politics that goes
much deeper and when a politics that
speaks to the heart because the only way
to fight you keep talking about how
we're gonna fight Donald Trump
you can't fight dog whistles you have to
override them and the only way you can
override them is with new voices voices
of energy that only come from the fact
that America has been willing to live up
to our own mistakes
a tone for our own mistakes make amends
for our own mistakes love each other
love our democracy love future
generations something emotional and
psychological that will not be be
emerging from anything on this stage it
will emerge from something I'm the one
who's qualified to bring forth
congressman Delaney okay that that's
that's her pitch and her pitch is
stronger than the picture of other
Democrats also I will point and you know
how you can tell this look at this
exchange you know elizabeth warren and
chris matthews every time i see state so
chris matthews gets all up in her grill
he's asking her very simple questions
about her policy nothing more does that
answer I roll out in here Terrell must
look like I just had seven drinks the
bar outside that's get a very simple
question Elizabeth Warren I'm just gonna
raise taxes on people you don't even
answer the question Elizabeth Warren
don't you have anything what are you
gonna say to that Elizabeth Warren cow
will you pay more in taxes but it's why
don't you answer that question because
cuz this Jake said tonight's a
Republican talking point it's not a
Republican time question so the question
is not do you have health insurance or
not have health
insurance the question is how much are
you gonna have to dig in your pocket
together I know that's the answer that
you'd like to give but nobody score
where theis Jenny is your total toss
okay but there's no answer to the
question really there is an answer to
the question about your cost its cost
that matters that is exactly right what
Chris Matthews is saying and she's got
nothing and Chris Matthews takes her
apart in 20 seconds flat right there now
check out marianne williamson who will
not she will not be owned by a child she
will own that child here's Mary Ann
Williams and being asked by a child
about if she has a pet this come on this
is great stuff this is fantastic um she
said the cat's dead guys sorry she did
have a cat and the cat died owning the
children with facts and logic marianne
williamson again I'm not saying marianne
williamson wins the nomination i'm
saying that if democrats keep playing
this game where they think that
radicalism for radicalism zones sake is
going to be the victorious notion
they're actually missing the appeal of
their own appeal which is a religious
appeal in nature williamson understands
this Barack Obama understood this in
2008 I'm not sure there's any Democrat
who really understands this and that's
why I think that they're having a real
rough time of Trump who makes a
spiritual appeal to Americans you may
not like his spiritual appeal
I don't like parts of his spiritual
appeal I think that spiritual Appeals in
politics as I said before are stupid and
wrong generally but I also think that
Williamson is doing something no other
Democrat is doing and if they can't
capture what she's doing they're gonna
lose okay one final note Don Lemon is
terrible
sometimes point out that Don Lemon at
CNN who helped moderate this debate is
awful at his job the fact that he is
considered as an objective journalist is
ridiculous here's a question that he
asked last night it's just insane what
do you say to those Trump voters who
prioritize the economy over the
president's bigotry oh yes that's that's
what by the way clapper chart gave the
right answer she said first of all Trump
voters don't do that from voters who
aren't just saying bigotry is fine but
as so long as I like the economics she
said I'm not gonna call Trump voters
racist but Don Lemon is fine calling
Trump voters racist right saying they
don't care if the president is a vicious
bigot so long
they get their tax cut what journalism
Inge from from Don Lemon
what a great objective journalist he is
CNN the most trusted name in news what a
joke
already normally I would do some things
I like in things I hate today but
frankly I'm all tuckered out from that
from that debate recap we'll have two
more hours of content for you later
today we'll go through some of the clips
that we weren't able to get to we will
also preview tonight's big debate and
Mario Lopez in trouble for saying
absolutely reasonable things about
transgender but we'll get into all that
a little bit later we'll do that or or
we'll see you here tomorrow I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
hey everyone its Andrew clave and host
of the Andrew Clavin show man it's good
to be a Democrat isn't it you go to
debate and who shows up to ask you the
tough questions other Democrats namely
the media now to their credit Jake
Tapper and Dana Bash did introduce with
the Democrat candidates called
conservative talking points and what the
rest of us call reality but there was a
much bigger talking point that went
unspoken all through the debate there
was one essential word missing we'll
talk about it on the Andrew Clavin show
I'm Andrew Clavin